defending my liberal principles has
become a conservative position so i find
it easy suddenly to build bridges with
with people that you know like glenn
beck and dennis prager and ben shapiro
that are looking to go wait a minute
maybe we can find some common ground
with liberals and i try to find i often
invite a lot of leftists on my show or
progressives and i get blocked or muted
or you know otherwise uh rejected but i
have had some too and i and i welcome
those kind of tell me about it
i know the feeling
well dave rubin host of the reuben
report once called himself a progressive
and even worked for a progressive news
outlet now he says he's fed up with the
modern left's autocratic tendencies and
cannot endorse them anymore dave rubin
joins us from los angeles dave thanks a
lot for coming on i i wanted to have you
on after i saw this amazing
uh video that you did that did go viral
explaining
why
you're at least shifting on if you're
abandoning all your formal beliefs but
you're reorienting for sure could you
just basically sum up what happened why
you changed your mind
yeah well you know first off actually i
believe the same liberal principles that
i've believed probably since around 1988
when michael dukakis was running against
george h.w bush and i was in a social
studies class where we were having a
mock election and i thought liberal was
good i mean the issue that that
everybody's talking about and by the way
i'm glad that i'm doing this tonight and
and with you because you're one of the
few people in the mainstream that are
that are now talking about this uh it's
been bubbling up online for quite some
time
and
the the progressive movement is no
longer progressive what progressive
would be would be truly liberal meaning
for the individual not for the
collective for liberty i would welcome
all your viewers to to google what
classical liberalism is it's about the
individual and your right to to do with
your life what you would like
this is not what the modern left is
about so i actually believe the same
exact things that i believe probably for
the last 30 some odd years
and it's the left that has gone crazy
and you know i know you know this but of
course on all this free speech stuff and
and judging everybody on their immutable
characteristics so if you're black we
judge you this way and if you leave the
group think you're a traitor if you're
muslim if you're trans gay et cetera et
cetera
these are reverse of liberal beliefs and
uh it's been very sad to see this i've
been trying to fight this on my show for
for a good two years now and i i suspect
we've lost that war in that i've lost
the left but i see an incredible new
center developing where people that are
liberal are now lining up and going wait
a minute i see a libertarian who can
come to the same agreement that i have
we can believe the same things just
looking at it through a different
political end so there's a beautiful
moment happening here but of course it's
lost in a big mess of of free speech
craziness and authoritarian nonsense
right and and part of the agreement that
might bring people who disagree with
each other together is that we're not
going to use the legal system against
each other if we can help it so you had
this line in here that struck out stuck
at me you said i am gay and married i do
not believe that a baker or a florist or
any business person ought to be forced
to bake a cake for a gay wedding because
if the government can force a company to
do something for one set of ideals they
can do it for any
so you see this as a threat to you
potentially
well of course i mean look you know i
should lay out you know i'm on fox news
and i know people will freak out oh my
god the liberals on fox news sure i
should give you some liberal cred look
i'm for gay marriage i even married a
guy i'm for legalizing marijuana i'm
pro-choice i'm for reforming the prison
system and the list goes on and on as
for that specific line i personally
wouldn't want the government telling a
private business what to do now a lot of
people will say wait a minute that sound
that sounds libertarian you just want
small government libertarianism again
this is actually a liberal principle and
i think this is something that most
people actually believe and i know
there's a lot of good people that would
argue with me and say well what if you
live in a small town and you know you
have a
a bigot is your baker in that one town
unfortunately i think this is a case
where you have to use your foot vote you
have to then take your skills and your
family and the money that you bring to
the community and move somewhere else or
order a cake online and i know that that
doesn't feel right to a lot of people
but that no that in and of itself this
this one person's bigotry shouldn't uh
be an excuse for more government
overreach and again that is a liberal
principle believe it or not yeah it is
to to the extent possible you know in
their cases where you have to but try
not to bother their people too much
that's that's one way to put it
that's the funny thing that uh live and
let live is a liberal principle and what
i've yes i found over the last couple
years especially is that defending my
liberal principles has become a
conservative position so i find it easy
suddenly to build bridges with with
people that you know like uh glenn beck
and dennis prager and ben shapiro that
are looking to go wait a minute maybe we
can find some common ground with
liberals and i try to find i often
invite a lot of leftists on my show or
progressives and i get blocked or muted
or you know otherwise
rejected but i have had some too and i
and i welcome those kind of tell me
about it
i know the feeling yeah i think we're
probably gonna be right on that
we we are on that to to look up your
video in line it's absolutely worth
seeing thanks a lot dave i appreciate it
i've seen a lot of videos of coming up
of that online actually the prequels are
good
yes is that only saying it for you is it
in comparison to these new ones it kind
of is yeah because it's like at least
the prequels don't hate star wars that's
the um they love but they're also
telling you just trying to use they're
telling you they're telling you a very
important story about how to get power
and where
where the desire for power comes from
and how you should be wary of political
power i mean in many ways they're
they're a really great sort of
conservative or libertarian story at
some level
are you more passionate about the first
amendment or star wars
well it's the first amendment that
protects my ability to say these radical
things that i say about star wars
from a certain point of view from a
certain point of view exactly i guess
exactly
what else is next on your computers over
here
i don't know where to go now it's like
recalculating yeah calculating
we needed an ai and it tells us what to
ask right he got that one right okay
a little flow chart
um who are some dream interviews do you
get anybody on your show left or right
well i'd really love to sit down with
bill maher i mean that's the one that i
feel like is like missing in my in my
hat sort of like you know because he is
that he is that old liberal that you're
talking about he really does get it when
it comes to free speech to when it comes
to what's happened to the liberals but
he can't and i think it's partly that
the guy's been doing it for 40 years
he's
multi-multi-millionaire you know he gave
a million bucks to obama so he sort of
fully showed his political cards there
um
but he can't seem to connect
that the democrats are the ones that are
destroying all of these cities so you
know he'll have adam schiff on and be
like you know all my friends are leaving
and ben shapiro left and joe rogan left
everyone's leaving california uh why is
that and it's like well wait a minute
you've got shift right in front of you
who raises taxes does all of the
horrible things that destroy this place
so he's just i think that's like a
hollywood thing he's so in bed with the
hollywood thing and yet at the same time
when it comes to the main issues he does
get it and also the trump thing kind of
broke him which if you know if trump if
trump had gone after me personally like
him and trump had had their their moment
personally so i grant him a little leash
with that but i just think we could
really
we could really
talk it out but also really argue about
like what would a true liberal do at
this moment where the world is splitting
do you want to just go down with the
ship which is what i think he's doing
with the left or do you want to see what
happens with these scary conservatives
and it's fairly obvious which one i'm
choosing i think we'd have a great talk
about that
yeah
so you have
shed your last
vestiges of liberalism are you
conservative are you coming out would
you like to come out to our audience
well
uh
you got a drink you got some whiskey
around yeah you guys got some whiskey
back there well yeah i would say anyone
sane at this point is conservative you
know what i mean like we might have a
couple
political disagreements so i would say
i'm still begrudgingly pro-choice 12
weeks
i'm not denying that it's life i know
that's like a big third rail one for
most traditional conservatives but i
think in a pluralistic society i mean i
go into this in the book you have to
have some
people are still gonna have abortions in
essence either way and i think
it'll end up being only rich people will
do it safely like there's a whole series
of issues there but look rudy giuliani
has been pro-choice for three decades
and also was at one time the leading
republican candidate for president you
know way back when and he's obviously a
conservative so for the minor things
that i would say that i have differences
with sort of like conservative 101
they're just irrelevant i want to live
in the same country as you guys i think
you want to live in the same country as
me we want to defend the principles that
have put us here and that is worth
conserving and the other guys want to
burn it down so it's like
it's just the choice is just so obvious
to me it's really as simple as that and
by the way when when i wrote the book
and i made that argument about abortion
most of my audience which is probably
more conservative than i am in a
traditional sense
the amount of fan letters that i got
that people were like you know dave i
love the book i disagree with you on
abortion but like maybe you'll come to
my position in a couple years who knows
or or i can just agree to disagree who
cares that's a spirit that that
i love and that's obviously it has
something to do with being conservative
yeah
do you want to live in the same state as
us though i feel like you guys should be
uh giving me a score after each and
every year because you look at each
other like you look at each other like
what are they telling you on that one
did you do okay well one of the
challenges of being a
yes we co-co
know if he's going to ask or i'm going
to
what you have you want to follow up i
don't know i do yeah i want to ask if
you want to live in the same state as us
or if you're going to follow the daily
wire and go to nashville yeah well you
know the story about me and knowles nols
came to my house
we get drunk we're like yes we're gonna
stay and fight and we'll take down gavin
newsom and we'll save california and
thus will save the union
and then when he leaves it's like three
in the morning we were like wasted i
wake up at 8 am i open up twitter daily
wire moving to nashville michael knowles
moving
he told me he claimed he didn't know
i'll take his word for it um look
everybody's leaving i mean candace left
obviously ben left you know rogan left
there's a
lot of other sort of hollywood type
friends that have all gotten out
i think let's see what happens with this
recall i mean i'm in it at least for now
but
at some point the rubber meets the road
and it's like you know do you want to
live in a place that feels very
antithetical to your
ideas and values and all of those things
on top of the fact that it obviously
makes no financial sense yeah to live
here but i'm okay with that you know the
thing is you pay the taxes because the
weather is so great that really is the
truth these last two weeks in socal has
been perfect every day that is worth
paying money for but at some point if
everyone leaves and there's more
homelessness everywhere and the drugs
are everywhere and the crime is
everywhere then it kind of becomes a
little bit tougher i for one appreciate
paying taxes to gavin newsom so he can
pay reparations so he can pay
reparations
yeah
god
killed flower he's guilty over something
that is not he although he probably has
lineage in his family than on slaves
although i wouldn't i wouldn't consider
him guilty because of that because no
one's guilty over their parents or
ancestors actions i mean they want you
to be born with original sin these
people they're crazy but if he wants to
pay out of his millions you know he's
got that winery and he's related to
nancy pelosi and she's worth a couple
hundred million right like he could paid
preparations but no one in my family
owned slaves and even if they did i
would not be guilty of it
right about people whose ancestors
abolish slavery
any points for that no no no you get
nothing you get nothing and you're
thankful for them
um
oh yeah we're okay so uh
boy we still have a lot of time i don't
know you looked over there oh jesus this
thing's we've already told the weather
yeah that was rough i should have looked
are you talked about the weather we
talked about star wars star wars weather
moving to tennessee
i would go to florida though if i was if
i was going i would go to florida there
there's so much going on there is there
any plan
miami's blowing up tech wise i'm going
there next week i'm going to interview
the mayor and he's just like he's taking
the refugees this guy he's he's
unbelievable he's like schindler this
guy he's like i will save all of you so
they leaving san francisco and they're
all just going down to miami and they're
building empires down there and
meanwhile san francisco is literally
wallowing in its own crapulence to quote
more isolated like so we can get it for
the podcast intro
san francisco is literally wallowing in
its own crapulence
we got it
it's wallowing in its own crapulin
smithers
all right what would it take for you to
become pro-life or a christian this
question was out of here i didn't write
that
who wrote that i think it was dan
dan so did you just ask did you just ask
the hardcore question and then back over
yeah totally back to it
i wiped my hands of this i'm fascinated
by your interview style two people that
constantly look at each other you might
be typing to each other in the middle of
this thing i don't know what the hell's
going on here welcome to a very special
edition of the reuben report
and i'm not reuben
i'm larry king and i will be
interviewing dave rubin
welcome to your show
this is wild larry
guest hosting my show from his studio
he's very nervous david this is all new
to me and uh
it's just uh it's spine tingling yeah
this must be very i mean you've
interviewed everybody but this has got
to be for for me pretty much
the tops this is that's really what
would you say like uh dalai lama top
three
oh no no dolly's way down dolly's down
there
i just don't know if i cracked the top
three basically so who are the top two
i'll pick one from entertainment will be
sinatra all right sinatra that's
respectable and one from the political
world seven presidents all the
presidents yeah yeah and now dave rubin
and dave rubin of the reuben report well
you're freaking out right now okay yeah
i can't tell you i'm nervous about it
were you a kind of were you a nerdy kid
who was interested in politics when he
was six years old you know i always
thought that i was right between
cool and nerd i remember around sixth
grade or something thinking that it was
gonna be work to be cool like the cool
kids to be around the cool kids because
i never felt cool and i was oh yeah i
was into science and video games and
board games and all that stuff but i
played sports too but i remember
thinking it would be very it would be
hard it would be effort to be with the
cool kids all the time and i knew i
would never be at the top of that thing
so i kind of hung out with the nerds and
and i loved it i i literally i kid you
not i did not
touch a sip of alcohol or or
smoke weed or a cigarette or anything in
high school i was up with my friends
playing video games everywhere you grow
up i grew up i was born in brooklyn just
like my esteemed interviewer and uh i
grew up in long island and lived in
manhattan for most of my adult life
until i moved to la four years ago so
i'm a i'm a true coast to coast guy
what'd your father do my dad was
in or is in sales for uh women's
clothing he's in the shemata biz
in new york when did you get interested
in politics
i think probably around seventh grade i
think it was uh
1988 was the dukakis
versus george h.w bush and i remember
very we were doing like a mock election
in my social studies class and i
remember uh george h.w bush had said to
dukakis you're a liberal and dukakis
said i'm no liberal or something to that
effect and i remember thinking
what this doesn't make any sense to me
liberals are the good guys why why would
you be afraid of saying you're a liberal
and that was really my awakening to
sort of being a liberal which to me
meant looking out for other people it
meant uh caring about the other and
trying to make sure that we have some
sort of cohesive society and not being
truly racist or bigoted in any of that
stuff
i think what's happened to the word
liberal especially in the last couple
years as i talked about on my show has
really changed um but i've always been
interested in politics i was a poli-sci
major so i may be i may be the only
person in america who got a poli-sci
degree and is actually using it
for something did you want to get into
the realm of running for office yeah i
did actually at first i thought i would
go into politics and i remember i was in
a politics class i think my junior year
of college i went to suny binghamton so
i came through the state system and you
know didn't have to spend a ton on
college and that's why i'm very much for
you know state funded education and i
remember being in a class
about public policy and the professor
everything that every day we'd be in
there he would talk about how nothing
works the way it's supposed to be
nothing the system just doesn't function
the way it is and i kind of remember
thinking
this doesn't seem right who would want
to be part of this system and i think a
lot of people feel that way which is why
it's really why we end up with such
corrupt candidates because who would
ever i mean
would you ever you know in your whole
lifetime would you have ever wanted to
go through that machine well the bible
is in all of that esquire did a great
article years ago on 100 people who
would be great presidents and you don't
know them yeah of course of course the
best of us
doesn't run yeah and it just seems so
obvious now and look you know we can
talk about trump and clinton and that
whole thing but it's like we got
somebody in office who you know i've
been saying i think this might be good
now i think there's some opportunity i
wonder about his moral center and you
know uh as i was just saying to you in
the green room i think he's a populist
not an ideologue so maybe there's a way
that the population can actually push
him to do good things as opposed to an
ideologue who really believes something
that could potentially be scary so i
think there's opportunity there but look
what he had to do to become president
you know crooked hillary and little
marco and lion ted and all this
stuff that has nothing to do with
politics it has nothing to do with you
know for 50 years that you've been
talking to all of these incredible
people how many issues were really
discussed
there was build a wall right which now i
think he's backtracking a little on
or you know deport these people now he's
backtracking on some of that stuff which
i think is actually fine but all of this
stuff it's like
does it doesn't feel like we had an
election it feels like we had a
popularity contest so you chose rather
than getting into the game
talking about the game asking about the
game yeah looking at the game i think
that
well for me and you know i'm talking to
the right guy now i mean that concept of
figuring out why
people think the way they think you know
like just sitting across from somebody
and and really trying to not grill them
actually i'll give you a question here
which is sometimes people say to me you
know dave you do too many softball
interviews and my policy on interviewing
is i want to watch them hang themselves
so i want to learn and i want to get it
the best way i can yeah and to me the
dumbest way to learn is to scream at
somebody
or to attack them or to make them
defensive yeah uh if you want to learn
like someone said if i if
somebody asked me if you were going to
interview
uh
oh
sodom hussein or
the guy who bombed
9 11.
i would i would have said to him
you were from one of the richest
families in saudi arabia yeah why'd you
leave
see i want to get at him i also knew a
long time ago that no one evil thinks
they're evil
so you don't comb your hair in the
morning hitler didn't comb his hair and
say i am a terrible person right he
thought he was doing pretty great stuff
right so you have to come at him from
the angle until you get to yeah you know
like i would love i used to interview
racists you know like george wallace
when he was governor before he changed
and i talk about the pigment of skin
what is it about
the pigment of skin yeah that would
cause you to think differently about a
person yeah why do you why do you buy
tanning lotion
right
and isn't that much more interesting
than just the the minutia of the
day-to-day
machine you know that i think that is
what the people are upset with more than
anything else they're sick of what cable
news has done to us this breaking news
they're breaking news literally i mean
they're breaking the way news should be
delivered to us and people are tired of
that they're you know this idea of
outrage culture that we're in very much
every morning you wake up and you can
look at twitter and figure out a
thousand reasons that people are
outraged
and then at the end of the day it's like
they're reporting it's like you've got
all these reporters and what are they
doing they're waiting for trump to tweet
they're just waiting for him to say
something so they can write a piece
about it and they can be outraged and
that's not news and it's also it's not
even good for your brain it's not good
for your ability to to do this to just
calmly for however long sit in front of
somebody
hear you respond that's what we need and
enjoy it don't you and you gotta leave
your ego at the door i try to i really
try to i mean
to me when i when i have a good
interview and the hour finishes i learn
something which is pretty great and i
would say almost every week
i've learned something
maybe not something good maybe i thought
well you know that guy said something
really crazy and i don't buy that but
i've had i've had interviews i had larry
elder on my show who i'm sure you know
larry
and larry is uh he's gonna frustrate you
he's well larry it was when i was doing
my show here at ora and he was in this
very room and he was really pushing i
was talking about systemic racism and he
was really pushing me on it what is
systemic about it he wasn't saying
racism doesn't exist but built into the
system and really pushed me on it and
has changed my views a little bit on how
it works uh and you know he gets a ton
of crap because he's a black
conservative so he's thought of as the
other and and he's treated really
terribly uh by by a lot of the black
community self-hating self-hating and
he's uncle tom and all this stuff so
i'll have him on and then i'll have
you know somebody like mike cernovich
who's thought of as an alt-right guy
and it you know either way i like having
those conversations it's like how would
you learn if you only listen to people
that you agree with
i have no idea
you're not kidding uh do you when you
see a race like we just had
do you get turned off from the game
man it's it's wild because this whole
last two years it's been exhilarating
for me in a certain way and and the fact
that i got to know you in these last
years and bring my show here and now do
it independently so it's been a good two
years for me sort of professionally and
and personally and all that
there are times when it's exhilarating
there are times when you really feel
like you're in something and you know
it's like when you're talking to people
that are actually really saying
something not not the interviews that
happen every now and again where you
know the guest isn't really offering
something they're either promoting
something or they're they're uh they're
just saying more of nothing for
publicity's sake right but sometimes you
talk to somebody you go wow this is this
is an idea that could actually change
people so
it's been exhausting i think everybody's
kind of exhausted right now we're having
this weird time in america right now
where people can't believe it like it
actually it happened the trump thing
happened i was saying i was on joe
rogan's show the day before the election
and i said i think this thing's 50 50. i
really believe that the whole time the
trump people were excited and the
hillary people were begrudgingly voting
for her or not voting and that's what
happened but it's so it's exciting and
it's also exhausting because i don't
know that this is exactly how politics
is supposed to be you know to me a good
political system would be one that we
don't have to talk about it that often
how do you beat the mob well the mob
actually preys on the fact that people
are afraid and i think there's a lot of
people that think oh if i could just be
i can sit this one out let me just sit
this one out let me be quiet this time
it'll pass it'll pass it doesn't pass
that's the thing they have preyed on the
fact that good people
are good people
and they have used that against us and
it's it's the frog in the boiling pot if
you think that your acquiescence or that
your silence is saving you
you're actually turning the dial up on
the pot that you're in
and as you know it does not end well for
the frog right like that frog is fried
at the end of that thing and i think
that that is what has happened here and
that that in many ways is why i wanted
to write the book more than anything
else because that was the idea it was
like
i don't think that everything i present
here is the most legendary political
idea of all time
but i think i've been able to
communicate ideas in a good way and and
i've paid the price for that um yeah
there are rewards
absolutely based on the price you paid
too and i don't say paid the price to
get any pity points i don't want any
pity points i've gotten the rewards of
that too right like it's it's awesome
it's
cool i wake up and i'm ready to go every
day you know how do you feel like we can
emotionally
arm ourselves
for
taking on backlash because if we want to
be great in our lives at any stage any
any uh decade of our life there's going
to be critics haters backlash mob
whether it's online offline whatever
what do you think we can do emotionally
to prepare for that besides what i think
is the best thing is just to do it as
often as
often as possible to be able to stomach
it and say okay i'm still alive i'm
still here yeah like it didn't kill me
it hurts yeah but i'm stronger well
partly it's that partly it's that partly
it's basketball's been a theme here so
like partly it's why did michael jordan
practice harder than anybody else right
like that is the known thing kobe was
like it too it's like why did they do it
barkley didn't love practice now allen
iverson famously practiced that you know
exactly and that's not to say they
weren't great players but alan iverson
and charles barkley never won
championships and michael jordan won six
championships and he was in the final
six times right he systematically
eliminated every one of his peers to get
there um so partly it's just that you
gotta you know douglas murray who i've
had on my show who's a brilliant
conservative political thinker from the
uk and one of the greatest writers that
i think we have in modern times um he
said to me once he said you know if you
get in the pool
he said in a british accent
if you dip your toe in the pool
you might find out that the water is not
that cold and i actually think that
that's the right idea we you know
there's nothing to fear but fear itself
it's something like that that we create
these monsters and then when you
actually go ahead and and do whatever
you're supposed to do you might step in
the pool and be like damn i thought the
water was gonna be freezing but it turns
out it's 92. that's fresh yeah and
that's not to say it's going to be
perfect because trust me it won't be you
will lose friends i mean we've all been
through versions of this people that you
love will suddenly say the worst things
about you you'll watch i'm seeing some
of this now i'm getting a lot of um
support from my sort of right-leaning
friend so you know shapiro and peterson
and glenn beck and dennis prager that
crew a lot of my my lefty guys who have
been with me all along the road have
completely abandoned me because they
don't want to just deal with any of the
backlash and i also think this is a
whole other topic but i think that goes
to a little bit of the lefty mind which
is in constant protection mode um that's
that's like sort of like a whole
separate thing but
you gotta get in
get in the game because the game is
coming for you anyway whether you like
you can say i'm not playing but it's
what we talked about with politics
before the game is being played man
you're that's like saying you know if we
were looking at a chess board it's like
you are one of the pieces whether you
like it or not and if the whole board is
being shifted around well you got to
move with it how do you handle
interviewing someone or sitting down
with someone who has every opposite
belief than you
who is so firm in their beliefs on
whatever opinion they have they
hate everything that you love yeah
how do you sit and listen to someone
with an opposing view
on everything about your life and your
beliefs and not let it affect you and
hurt you
yeah is that possible
so i can give you two examples of this
i'll give you one on the left and one on
the right because it's a because the
premise that you're asking could apply
to no matter where you fall right so on
the left i interviewed marianne
williamson you know her right the
democratic candidate the yeah so i
interviewed her and
as i was interviewing her lovely lady
yeah
maybe a little out there that's fine too
that was part of the magic but what i
realized about 20 minutes into the
interview is we had a fundamental
impasse on how we view the world she's a
collectivist and i'm an individualist
she believes sort of in collective guilt
so she had just done this thing a few
weeks earlier in a church about this
year you saw this about the uh slavery
about yeah and that she had the white
people in the church go up to the black
people and touch them and basically
apologize and it's like i don't believe
you're guilty for your father's sins
your grandfather's sins much less
no one in my family owned slaves that's
not to say that we we should not realize
that obviously slavery was a horrible
thing and all of those things but i
don't believe in collectivism that white
people are suddenly guilty of something
or black people inherently are not
guilty of something or guilty or saying
i just don't believe the world operates
like that i believe the world operates
you are responsible for your thoughts
and actions now she obviously viewed the
world in a very different way and that's
very obvious in all of her policies and
all of the things that she was putting
forth and i realized as an interviewer
in that moment
i thought i could let her say whatever
she want and i will and i'll treat her
respectfully but if i don't stop right
now and announce we just have a
fundamental difference on how we view
the world then everyone's going to look
at me and be like dave everything she
said up there for an hour is completely
against what you say but you just let
her say it so i felt the best way to to
deal with that was to just make the
announcement just make the announcement
we just view the world
differently there you go um
not making it wrong
or bad do i do i believe that my view of
the world is closer to something that
will uh ultimately free people
absolutely but i it's not interesting to
me to to bring on people to just attack
them yeah i'm not interested in doing
that someone else could do that that's
fine that's not what i want to do you're
more of a neutral yeah like me yeah well
yeah it's because this is how you get i
i it's very obvious to me that you don't
have an agenda with me you're actually
trying to find out what i think that's
much more in line with mike
than trying to gotchas and by the way
man i say this all the time if a million
you know i was kind of early on the long
form interview thing on youtube but if a
gajillion other people start being out
there doing it better than me i will
find other things to do like i really
like writing the book i like doing
public stuff and talking to the camera
and tours and all that so so that's why
it's like i never feel a competition in
any of these things it's like man if you
blow up it's like that's awesome like
you're doing something good i really
mean that like that's cool like i can do
other things i wanted to be in the nba
it's too late
but uh but i'll give you the right
version of that as well which was i had
this guy by the name of stefan molyneux
do you know who he is so he's a youtube
guy who's become a bit of a cult figure
and he talks a lot about race realism
and sizes of brains and all of this
stuff that i am i was never particularly
interested in it's not my thing there's
a twang
of what feels like genuine racism in it
like i don't even mean that he himself
is racist per se but if you're obsessed
with that topic it always strikes me as
like
a little bit weird yeah and it was one
of the only interviews that i've ever
done maybe maybe literally the only one
i've ever done where i actually called a
couple people to ask for advice on how
to go about doing this
because i wanted to treat him
respectfully the same way i would treat
everybody else but i also wanted to make
sure i wasn't not getting attacked by
the world first well i knew that was
going to happen no matter what i knew
the world i knew that either way was
going to happen right
but so i talked to a couple people and i
felt that i dealt with the interview
correct my my driving point in the
interview
was i kept saying to him i think i said
it three times why do you care about
this why do you care about whether there
are racial differences related to brain
size and iq like what and i don't know
that he gave me an answer that perfectly
answered it for me but i also think as
an interviewer if i'm never to touch i'm
sure you have your own version of this
if i'm never to touch the people that
are on the fringes then what will happen
is the fringes will keep getting tighter
and tighter you know what i mean like
we'll keep getting a slimmer and slimmer
version of who we can talk to
and you know it's sort of like the alex
jones thing it's like listen alex jones
may be a nut bag he may be really a wwe
style wrestler more than a political
pundit or he may be half actor and half
conspiracy theorist it doesn't even
matter what he is but the idea that this
was the guy that we had to take out
online i'm not defending anything he
said i'm not i'm not lauding it or
defending it i'm just saying when they
do this coordinated assault to just
eliminate somebody what in effect what
they did is they made him more popular
i've heard from people on the on the
inside that he's actually making more
money than he's ever made before because
they drove his core fans to him right to
however he makes money i'm not even sure
that is maybe it's through his website
or whatever they drove it all to him so
instead of giving the youtube rev and
the which you know is pretty crappy and
you know the nub the cpms and all that
nonsense so so i'm i'm just a believer
that
for guys like us we have to do our best
to to talk to
some people that maybe aren't loved by
everybody and then and then survive the
slings that'll come with it
it's just what you got to do or get it
into another line of work that's it
you can't stomach it yeah if you can't i
hear you yeah i try to um
yeah i try to really make sure that i'm
never like attacking someone or anything
like that when i'm interviewing them
it's really trying to pull the best out
of them and
make sure that also that i'm not saying
this is also what i believe in i think
that's good that you do that and but
well because that's the tricky part
because sometimes someone will say
something
that everyone knows that i think is is
wrong or the wrong idea and it's like i
don't feel it's like like some people
don't need to constantly justify yeah i
don't see that's the thing i don't want
to adjust to my justify myself i may
push them and say you know well i don't
really understand i mean if you if you
keep giving money to the thing that you
say doesn't work maybe that's not going
to work you know something like that
well that you can do that but but then
it gets to a point where it's like if
they came on my show which is in my home
yeah literally yeah it is literally in
my home i i'm not there to destroy them
and as far as i know no one has been
killed because of any of the ideas that
have been put forth on the reuben report
um kind of on the tangent then about
talking about liberalism and progress
progressivism in general and sort of
you've often spoken about how these two
ideologies have changed and how they've
almost become a race checking what you
coined as the highest rate of victimhood
what do you think is actually driving
this change
look the the ideas of identity politics
as i said where you judge people on
their immutable characteristics so for
example we we just met
10 minutes ago i i don't know what your
background is i can only look at you and
i can ascertain a few things but if i
was to think okay your skin is darker
than mine i should know what your
politics are or i should know any
literally anything about you other than
you strike me as a very thoughtful
person and i'm enjoying this
conversation that would that would be
insane i mean that would really that
would be insane but they've tricked us
in a modern sense the left has tricked
us to say okay if you're gay you're a
little oppressed but if you're a white
gay guy you're a little less oppressed
than a black gay guy and then if you're
a muslim you're oppressed this much and
if you're trans you're oppressed this
much and then there's this idea that i'm
sure most of you guys know about
intersectionality that somehow if we can
combine all of these oppressions
you know it's like you're creating some
sort of super transformer that will be
stronger together
you know like devastated i'm glad that
reference worked on you guys wow all
right
um i'd rather talk about the
transformers but we can do this um
but they think that if that by taking
all of these oppressed groups that what
you can do is you can mix them all
together and that you'll have some sort
of superpower but you will actually have
the reverse because if you view
your victimhood as virtue you will
always want to be more of a victim than
anyone else and victimhood guys this is
probably the most important thing that
i'll say this entire time victimhood is
not virtue yes some of you grew up with
more some of you have a limp some of you
are gay some of you are black whatever
it is it does not matter what you are
supposed to do as a human is take charge
of your life figure out what your can i
curse
[ __ ] is figure it out figure out what
your [ __ ] is and then and then go all
right you know look everyone in this
room i i would guarantee you
that almost without exception but please
correct me if i'm wrong in the q a that
almost every single one of you have it
better than your grandparents had and
certainly better than their parents had
and before that
that's real progress but it's not
progress it's not progress because it
magically happened
its progress
because freedom has taken root here and
that is an incredibly beautiful thing so
all the government should do is
facilitate to make sure that there are
equal laws for everybody that you don't
get to take more from some people
because they had a little bit easier or
give more to some people because they
had a little bit harder now there's ways
we can address some of those things i
would say that the way to address real
inequalities are that we should be
funding the best
education we can fund that to me is the
only answer but the idea that we're
going to punish certain people or i'm
sure many of you guys are familiar with
the uh with the lawsuit that james
damore has over at google i mean they
literally were putting it in hr
handbooks that they were not going to
hire white or asian engineers really
think about that you're going to say
because of someone's skin color or
ethnicity we are not going to hire them
now i get it the idea behind that was
we'd like to help other people who maybe
have been underrepresented as engineers
and that's a lofty idea and it sort of
sounds like progress we're going to hire
people who have been underrepresented
but what you actually start
accomplishing is that you will hire
people not only who are less qualified
because you're going to say we're going
to have to take people who are less
qualified if if in this case the white
and asian engineers were the most
qualified and any business hopefully you
guys will all have great businesses when
when you get out of here if you want to
have a great business or you'll be in
academia or whatever else you want to do
but you're going to want to hire the
best people not because of their skin
color that is prejudice imagine if you
had a heart attack tomorrow would you
want the best doctor or would you want a
doctor based on some immutable
characteristic that got him the job that
probably also got him into the college
before that and then perhaps the school
before that of course the answer is no
that's the honest answer it's a tough
answer but that's the honest answer so i
would say the way to deal with some of
the inequalities is through education
um
but this
this positioning of
of that our victimhood will make us
stronger together is actually especially
for america which i think has done
multiculturalism better than any western
society in the history of the world
where everyone you know this is a funny
thing we get this out of the left all
the time how much they hate america and
then they also want open borders so i
guess everyone could share in the horror
that is america and
it's it's just it i mean it's patently
ridiculous and
we should we should want equal laws for
everybody and then within that that is
what empowers you as an individual to go
out and get what's yours it doesn't mean
you're going to get it
but you should have
every opportunity to get it and then the
rest is on you and any other system
that's going to try to rejigger some
things so that it's going to be easier
for these people and less easy for these
and try to magically
make a perfect society as eric weinstein
said on my show every time a society is
tried for utopia it gets dystopia
then kind of on that tangent the idea
that education could be the first step
to more equal society
how would you then navigate the problem
that comes with an educational
institution for example oxford one could
argue where bme students are
underrepresented represented when it
comes to the application process if it's
not through then schemes that encourage
these communities to apply how how do
you suggest to navigate around that
issue yeah so i don't know about that
specific example
so i don't want to comment on that but
what i would say is that we shouldn't be
looking i mean look if you took the
entire country here and you were to
break it down by ethnicity or whatever
or sexuality or whatever imagine if
those quotas were really what got you
guys to school some of you would not be
here right now would that be fairer i
don't i don't think that would be fairer
what you would want to do i think is you
want to get education to be at the most
local level possible but really good
education not just teaching for the test
so that people can move higher up and
and they so they can memorize certain
stats or sir you know i'm sure all of
you guys did this in high school you
would ask your teacher well do i have to
know years or something you know like
and it's like that's not what an
education is what you have to try to do
i think is get
as much
you want to use money effectively so
that schools actually are teaching
logical thinking critical thinking
critical thinking more than anything
else
and then yes may it turn out at the end
of that if everyone had basically the
same access school choice is a great
example in vouchers people should have
as much access to good education and by
the way this is somewhere where i think
the government does have a role so
there's a lot of libertarians obviously
that don't want the government in
education at all i would say that i i'm
the product of public education for
better or worse and i i went to
you know good grade school i went to
junior high and a blue ribbon high
school and i went to the state
university of new york at binghamton
all public schools so i know it can work
i studied politics so i must something
must have gone right here you know um
so i think you have to
reform it to the point where we
shouldn't have fed federal bureaucracies
like the department of education that's
trying to impose
just massive we have in america for
example we have about i don't know 350
million people 400 million people you
have to kick that back to the states and
let the states decide what's best and
then the counter argument i always get
to that by the way is that when people
say well wait a minute if you took a
state like you know a southern state
like alabama well they'd want to teach
creationism well perhaps they would but
i would argue that as time goes forward
i believe
that the truth does win out and that the
more opportunity you give if the states
are actually a marketplace which is what
the founders in america wanted the more
that wow you go
um you know one of some of the
connecticut in the north they've really
respected science and education and all
that i'm just i'm just picking a state
uh you're gonna get more people moving
there and then connecticut might raise
taxes and then more people are going i
don't want to pay those taxes for that
education and they might move to texas
and they'll get to texas and the taxes
will be low but they'll go all right my
taxes are low but my education is not
great but i have more land here and then
it's on you i mean this is the true
beauty of the american system is that
you can use as randy barnett who's been
on my show as a constitutional law
professor at georgetown and he's argued
in front of the supreme court he said
you can use your foot vote if you don't
like what is happening in your community
go somewhere else but the second the
federal government starts making laws
for everybody if you don't like it you
got to leave the country and that that's
much worse so again this is where i
would always go to to local control of
things
on then talking about educational
institutions i think now more than ever
on like college campuses the idea of
safe spacing and not platforming is a
buzzword that's very prominent
would you ever not host a speaker for
example well i think everyone has a
right to free speech and i hope during
the q a you guys are welcome to ask me
anything anything that you'd like i
don't think everyone has a right to a
platform or i know that not everyone has
a right to a platform you don't have to
invite anyone here and you don't have to
sit here to listen to anyone um
so that's up to that's up to the
organization now i would say that a
school
a public school especially private
schools it's a little bit different but
in effect if a public school invites a
student group invites somebody
then the school has a responsibility to
make sure that event can happen
peacefully and that protest of course is
allowed protest is the most free thing
that there is you are supposed to use
your voice to express your thoughts but
you can't violently protest you can't
call in bomb threats you can't um pull
fire alarms you can't create human walls
to not let other students in these are
all things that happened to me when i
spoke at ucla with milo
now again milo is intentionally a
provocateur so i don't agree with all of
the things that he says absolutely but
if the student group decided that he can
speak it's incumbent on the university
to protect his free speech and uh so
this idea of safe spaces and trigger
warnings look they can again i'm a
freedom guy they can do whatever they
want if you guys have a room of puppies
or whatever is out there like great well
great i guess it's not great but you can
have your room of puppies
um i'd like to see the room of puppies
but like
but
in effect you're you're what you're
doing is actually the reverse of why you
guys are here you are here to learn how
to think this is the incredible what an
incredible school you're at i mean just
in the hour that i've been here i mean
this is this is truly incredible and i
hope you guys really understand that
and if they take away your ability to
hear different thoughts
in school you don't magically get braver
you don't magically get smarter when you
work out you know you get into the real
world now you got a job and you got kids
and a partner or whatever you got you're
not gonna magically also go now i should
challenge my mind intellectually you
won't do it here now and the more people
that are trying to protect you from
scary ideas they're actually not
protecting you they're they're
sheltering you and if anything they're
really trying to control you so not
everybody has a has a right to speak
well everyone has a right to speak but
not everyone has a right to speak here
it's up for you guys to make wise
choices and in the cases where maybe you
invite somebody that some of the people
here aren't happy with they can protest
but i would say more importantly come
come listen and make a good point in the
q a and and show this person why they're
wrong but just shouting them down
actually strengthens all the bad forces
out there if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell